[Musica]
sapete tutti cosa sono
soprattutto in questa stagione
la maggior parte di noi prova fastidio o
addirittura disgusto per l'infelice
abitudine di questi insetti di radunarsi
fin dentro le nostre abitazioni
in realtà in agricoltura il problema è
stato molto più serio e hanno fatto
davvero parecchi danni da quando sono
comparse soprattutto in frutticoltura in
orticoltura
dovendo trovare delle soluzioni negli
ultimi anni se n'è parlato molto e
proprio la strategia vincente ci tornerà
utile tra qualche minuto purtroppo però
abbiamo ben di peggio delle cimici
asiatiche la crisi climatica e quella
della biodiversità potrebbero avere un
impatto devastante sulle coltivazioni
per cui non dovrebbero esserci dubbi sul
fatto che sia prioritario occuparsene e
che l'agricoltura debba svolgere un
ruolo centrale nei processi di contrasto
e resilienza
mi sto parlando di agricoltura perché mi
appassiona da una vita e anche se me ne
occupo in una dimensione un po
particolare
mi interessa molto capire come sta
affrontando le sfide del presente e
dell'immediato futuro
la riflessione che vi propongo oggi
nasce proprio dalla fatica che
l'agricoltura sta manifestando nel
confrontarsi con questi scenari decisivi
nonostante la loro portata e la loro
urgenza
quando decisi di iscrivermi a scienze
agrarie
avevo ben chiaro che l'agricoltura è un
settore strategico ed economico
fondamentale
ma ero mosso soprattutto da passione e
idealita
sono passati tanti anni ma resto
convinto non solo che lo slancio possa
convivere con la razionalità ma che il
binomio sia indispensabile e vada
incoraggiato per ottenere equilibri
virtuosi
la cosa interessante e per certi versi
curiosa è che la situazione attuale
sembra riproporre questo dualismo
anche se la sintesi pare molto lontana
da un lato abbiamo chi ci ricorda con
toni quasi ricattatori che a livello
planetario dovremmo sfamare 10 miliardi
di bot
e non c'è spazio per nient'altro
dall'altro abbiamo le istituzioni
europee che lanciano una sfida folle per
passare ad un sistema alimentare
sostenibile che possa portare benefici
ambientali
sanitari sociali ed economici
ovviamente non c'è nulla di folle però
va ammesso che l'asticella è stata
posizionata ad un'altezza decisamente
impegnativa soprattutto per gli standard
a cui siamo abituati
il mio timore però è che in questo caso
la razionalità anziché fungere da faro
stia scivolando verso il cinismo e si
voglia rigettare una sfida che ha
innanzitutto culturale
anziché raccogliere la provocazione
si è invocata l'ideologia per minarne le
basi e si è passati direttamente al
dileggio
ci dicono l'agricoltura è una cosa seria
la sostenibilità che qui si evoca è roba
da ambientalisti
il problema è che ovviamente la sfida la
provocazione non nascono da un colpo di
testa
ma in risposta a un mondo che sta
cambiando velocemente
e ad un futuro che non promette nulla di
buono
la cosa per me
insostenibile che si consideri tra le
opzioni la possibilità di rigettare
tutto quasi a non voler vedere tra i
costi proprio quelli che vengono
generati dal cambiamento climatico
e doveroso ammettere che ci troviamo in
una situazione estremamente complessa e
così come ritengo ciniche ed i
responsabili certe posizioni
non posso tacere sul fatto che anche il
green deal e i suoi strumenti che
richiedono degli approfondimenti o
quantomeno le migliori declinazioni caso
per caso
il rischio di azioni di facile impatto
mediatico ma di scarsa sostanza e dietro
ogni angolo e sarebbe davvero un peccato
perdersi in fumosità inutili se non
addirittura dannose
c'è anche il rischio che le transazioni
economiche prevalgano sulle transizioni
ecologiche
la passionalità europea si concretizza
agganciandosi alla politica agricola
comune nel momento in cui chiede delle
azioni mette anche mano alla borsa per
questo vi ho parlato di sfida culturale
se io adotto delle pratiche solo perché
c'è un beneficio economico sarà comunque
meglio di niente ma avremmo perso
un'occasione forse non ripetibile per
mettere finalmente a sistema queste
innovazioni
la sensazione di urgenza effettivamente
presente anche a seguito di recenti
danni da eventi atmosferici estremi
abbiamo sentito dichiarazioni che
sottolineavano quanto fosse pesante
l'impatto del cambiamento climatico
sui raccolti e sulle strutture aziendali
quindi il mondo agricolo è d'accordo sul
fatto di dover reagire ma rigetta
vigorosamente gli strumenti proposti
il dibattito è salutare ovviamente però
la mia sensazione che non si voglia
affidare questi strumenti ma
semplicemente accantonarli
ci dicono che l'agricoltura attuale ha
fatto passi importanti
i racconti fatti è praticamente perfetta
così
sulla carta possiamo convenire su molte
cose per carità però girando per le
nostre campagne non è così facile
trovare conferme significative
la mia sensazione è che si stia
ragionando come se esistesse un unico
modello possibile di agricoltura
l'intensificazione sostenibile dalle
produzioni agroalimentari
come slogan suona molto bene ma sarebbe
un errore pensare che sia ottenibile con
un semplice affinamento dell'esistente
in realtà servirebbe mettere la ricerca
nelle condizioni di produrre più
velocemente possibile degli strumenti
capaci di innescare una vera rivoluzione
insomma anche in questo caso il mio
timore che si evochi una sostenibilità
che verrà per giustificare un
sostanziale immobilismo del presente
e mentre noi siamo fermi lo scenario
drammaticamente dinamico in parte ormai
fuori dal nostro controllo
forse non è più sufficiente parlare di
input e residui
quando avremo sempre minori probabilità
di portare a termine un ciclo colturale
senza incappare in un evento atmosferico
estremo che possa distruggere tutto
questa nuova incertezza dovrebbe far
capire che la posta in gioco è altissima
e servono davvero tutte le risorse
disponibili
che fare quindi beh tanto per cominciare
più di qualcuno è convinto che la
sostenibilità dell'agricoltura abbia
bisogno di un'agricoltura plurale che
sappia affrontare complessivamente alla
sostenibilità utilizzando caso per caso
i migliori sistemi disponibili
in sostanza si tratta di non rigettare
nulla per partito preso
ma di operare delle scelte
partendo dalla vocazionalità dei
territori non dovremmo vedere
antagonismi ad esempio tra l'agricoltura
biologica e le vertical farm o tra le
coltivazioni cui siamo abituati ed altri
sistemi in grado di proteggere dalle
avversità atmosferiche
in aggiunta a questo andrebbero
ovviamente implementate delle strategie
per sostenere le necessità alimentari
a cominciare da campagne per la
riduzione degli sprechi e per
l'orientamento delle diete
passando poi alle protezioni ottenibili
fuori dai campi grazie a nuove
tecnologie ea nuovi prodotti
in questo modo oltre ad alleggerire le
pressioni sull'agricoltura classicamente
intesa che a fare dei passi avanti per
la sicurezza alimentare
potremmo finalmente riaprire le opzioni
sull'uso del suolo
già perché il mantra dell'agricoltura
odierna è che non possiamo rinunciare
nemmeno ad un metro quadrato di suolo
anche quando si tratta di valorizzarlo
nonostante si moltiplichino le conferme
di quanto sarebbe importante
rimettere biodiversità nel sistema si
continua a parlarne come di concessione
all'ambientalismo
o nella migliore delle ipotesi
di ulteriori aggravi per il sistema
agricolo a fronte di benefici di
benefici per altri
in realtà si potrebbe ripartire proprio
dai principi dell'agroecologia e più in
generale da sistemi agrari che si
lascino permeare dalla biodiversità
grazie ad infrastrutture ecologiche che
favoriscano la riconnessione con
contesti meno compromessi
proprio su questo vorrei coinvolgervi in
un ragionamento e lasciarvi con una
proposta
io sono convinto che la sostenibilità
ambientale dell'agricoltura non si
giochi prioritariamente negli spazi
coltivati abbiamo conferme che dal punto
di vista della biodiversità
non ci sono differenze sostanziali tra
sistemi biologici e convenzionali
se ci limitiamo a guardare dentro le
coltivazioni
un po perché fortunatamente
l'agricoltura convenzionale è migliorata
in termini di impatto
molto però perché comunque la
coltivazione uno stravolgimento a
prescindere soprattutto se si adottano
le classiche lavorazioni
quindi è quello che lasciamo fuori dai
campi e come lo gestiamo a poter fare la
vera differenza il dramma è che oggi
lasciamo sempre meno che gestiamo anche
peggio
per anni ci siamo concentrati
sugli impatti dell'agricoltura in
termini di singole molecole e ci siamo
dimenticati che la stessa agricoltura
occupa superfici vastissime che non
possono essere ridotte a sommatorie di
apprezzamenti un territorio vive di
connessioni e le campagne non fanno
eccezione
servono aree di compensazione e corridoi
ecologici
per ricostituire trame di relazioni
positive
il discorso è molto vasto ma volendo
semplificare e limitarsi agli elementi
permanenti
potremmo concentrarci sulle siepi
campestri e sulle fasce i nervi
anche solo gestendo meglio le cosiddette
tare aziendali e destinando pochissimi
punti percentuali di suolo agricolo si
potrebbero spalancare le porte ad una
biodiversità che sarebbe utile non solo
al territorio ma la stessa agricoltura
potrei farvi tantissimi esempi
sull'importanza di organismi ausiliari
che verrebbero a trovarsi nell'immediata
prossimità delle coltivazioni
ma c'è un caso dello scorso anno
particolarmente eloquente per
contrastare la cimice asiatica la stessa
di prima ricordate sono stati
autorizzati lanci inoculati vi di me
notteri parassitoidi delle vespertine
capaci di deporre le proprie uova dentro
le uova della cimice interrompendone
così il ciclo riproduttivo
a differenza però di altri esempi di
lotta biologica i lanci non vengono
fatti direttamente sulle coltivazioni ma
su siepi e macchie di vegetazione nelle
loro immediate vicinanze
messa così sembra un dettaglio tecnico
ma se non ce ne fossero più state
sono anni che le siepi vengono distrutte
quasi nessuno ne parla e tutt'a un
tratto diventano indispensabili per
aiutarci a combattere un vero flagello
non è che siano tornati in auge per
questo è sì continua tranquillamente a
non parlarne tra l'altro quasi nessuno
ha reso loro il merito per questo ruolo
che hanno svolto contro la cmc asiatica
ovviamente i benefici non si limitano a
questo aspetto particolarmente evidente
o ad altri particolarmente eclatanti ma
il punto che vorrei sottolineare
è che le siepi campestri e più in
generale le infrastrutture ecologiche
delle campagne poterle ripristinare e
proteggere è un'azione trasversale alle
varie tipologie di agricoltura
non ci sono scuse per tirarsi fuori a
prescindere da come si gestiscono le
coltivazioni
le siepi rappresentano un valore
intrinseco capace di contaminare
positivamente
scenari anche molto diversi tra l'altro
a livello simbolico potrebbero
addirittura rappresentare uno spazio di
confronto
per provare a sgretolare il muro contro
muro tra forme diverse di agricoltura
va ricordato che è stata la
meccanizzazione
a dare la spinta decisiva la
devastazione della complessità delle
campagne
portandola una banalizzazione sul piano
ecologico
però oggi le innovazioni in agricoltura
di precisione e ancor di più nella
robotizzazione
lasciano intravedere scenari molto meno
vincolanti in termini di dimensioni e
manovrabilità che potrebbero favorire il
processo inverso
inoltre si tratta di gestire con
intelligenza le superfici già
disponibili ai margini dei campi
basti pensare alle reti idriche e alla
viabilità minore con km chilometri
facilmente convertibili in
infrastrutture ecologiche senza bisogno
di sottrarre altre aree alla produzione
agraria
infine ogni giorno sentiamo annunci per
piantare alberi in numeri esorbitanti
che una cosa giusta anche se molto più
complessa di quel che sembra
ma per piantare tanti alberi servono
superfici importanti per piantare siepi
lo spazio sostanzialmente c'è già e
mentre si agisce per la biodiversità si
compie un'azione importante anche per
contrastare il cambiamento climatico
insomma l'agricoltura occupa superfici
troppo vaste perché possiamo permetterci
di non considerare la valenza ambientale
e non possiamo nemmeno permettersi di
pensare solo ad aree di eccellenza vera
o presunta che sia e trascurare tutto il
resto la sostenibilità dell'agricoltura
quasi per definizione ha bisogno di
tutta l'agricoltura
forse si tratta di superare un approccio
che vede incompatibilità dove invece le
potenzialità non mancano
cominciando a ridare valore alle azioni
più semplici e più trasversali
che spesso sono proprio lì a portata di
mano
che l'agricoltura ci serve per avere da
mangiare è in dubbio
ricordiamoci che è indispensabile anche
se vogliamo provare a salvare il pianeta
per riuscirci servono conoscenze e
razionalità ma anche almeno un pizzico
di passione
[Applauso]